sorry i don't want to be a dick right or  anything i've impacted my life so much  and i i don't want to ask anything or  anything i just want to thank you thank  you for all you've done thank you thank  you you made me realize like i don't  know for for forever i was chasing the  dollar yeah and like i thought that  would solve all the problems in my life  never and it won't as a matter of fact  it accelerates the problem right and i  just want to help people in this life  and so you made me realize that and uh  it's awesome man i really appreciate you  thank you mike mike you're gonna hear my  name more i can't wait well what's your  last name because there's a [ __ ] load of  mikes mike from you but you'll know me  as element pleasure